That's the weirdest thing about comedy. It can work one night and not the next.
And you're like just the same wording, same delivery guy. But Hey.
[Inaudible].
New Jersey and the green room of the stress factory,
great club shameless plug, and then help me.
Cause I'm already here and show's happening in 10 seconds, but, uh, yeah,
we're gonna try some new jokes. Try them out on Twitter or something like that.
Okay. And then we've got two shows a night, so we'll try it on the first show.
See what happens, tweak. Try it on the second show.
And if you want to go back tomorrow, that'll be a couple more shows,
but I don't know. You got kids. You're getting late. Gay.
I don't know what you got going on. Hold on. Oh, that was a legit story.
Doug should be fun. I guys going to tick away. There you go.
And uh, last time was a hot show. Let's hope for another one. It's Friday night,
Rosh Hashanah, Jewish new year.
Thanks for the extra holidays there Jews. All right,
we'll see you out there.
This is one of those better setups. Winter is going to bring.
She's really weird. This is a full hour.
All know this is Corona only,
and this is the new ones I need to try to get into it.
How do you feel coming off that show
over overall?
[inaudible] I swear to God. Oh my God. Wow.
We just did a Friday early show.
Now we're doing Friday late show this show Friday Lake show.
Typically not always, typically a little more tired,
a little boozier they've been day drinking or they've been, uh,
boozing at dinner and then they come to a 10 o'clock show.
This one could be a little dicey. Uh, so we'll see what happens.
[Inaudible]
I appreciate it.
These are weird times, you know, let's be honest.
I can't believe we're all here. Some guy up bad
schools are closed. You know what sucks with the parents? Great for me though,
because now I can drive again. Yeah.
All things crazy. I made it. What are we? Six months in now?
Kronos started building the check engine light. At first it was scary.
Like, it. I gotta go to work. The news is a bummer. How about that?
He's cute. It's still a little, it's like a COVID Brown bone.
Every time I see him, like I only got six more weeks of pandemics.
Thanks for coming on. I know it's cold. Hey, good to see. I was at cocaine
[inaudible] I don't know. I just so sick of this stuff, you know,
starting to feel like a middle Eastern woman, an arranged marriage.
I do what I'm told or cover my face. And I say my opinion. I get yelled at
my on acid or is this breathing
real bricks
just keeps coming up over like a Duisburg at the shore.
[inaudible] tonight. Show comedy central a good, a silver Honda is getting.
Sports are trying to come back. Sports are weird.
There's nobody in the seats watching a basketball game. The stands are empty.
Weird. It's eerie. I got an idea.
All those braces badges are torn down. Put them
somewhere to go make the players play better a little bit. I'm like, you.
[inaudible] here.
[inaudible] let me say this. When I wrote those jokes for you,
[inaudible]
kind of say I was way off. The second show was way better. They were hot.
I mean the new stuff work. The old stuff work. The ending was good.
I estimated wrong.
I assumed assumption is the mother of all anal. What is it? Uh,
have you assume you make an out of me and your dad, whatever it is,
but I was way off and they were hot and I loved him.
I every there and I'll never stop loud. You're the one.
Thank buddy. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thought he was a fan that turned out.
He was brownie. No, thank you though.
Yeah. Thanks for coming. Give me a hunch shoe. Oh,
knows that my mom, but Hey, I was a Cub scout. I've been in a tent before
on the last show, but don't worry.
I was a Cub scout and this isn't the first time I've been
[inaudible] here. We are Jersey Saturday night.
Look at the heat lamps going that guy's hard.
[inaudible].
A couple of people were just giving me the in the evil eye, you know, just like,
and you want to be like this nuts? Well, normally there's nothing worse than,
than a crowd going like this. Guy's not that good. And I'm like, it works.
I swear to God at work.
[Inaudible].
Crowd is good. Like last night, I I'm not even thinking of my act.
I'm just like, it's almost like you're floating. You're just in it. It's like,
you're surfing. Like I'm on the wave tonight. I can. I was,
I felt like I was just paddling the whole time.
They had to stop the shooting. Batman,
the Batman movie had to be stopped because Batman got to Rome,
which I'm not shocked by because the wrong part of his face is covered.
What can you do?
We were talking a little bit yesterday. How? Like,
you're not like a big laugh out loud kind of guy.
Do you feel like when you're in the audience,
do you like if it was an audience full of you.
It would be horrible. And I, I I'm aware of that would be a lot of, uh,
a bunch of marks going. Yes, yes. Which I get that guy.
If I'm that guy, other people gotta be that guy, but I don't get the anger.
You know? Like the, you know,
it's almost like there are not happy to be out and I'm like, you came out.
I didn't make you do this.
Let's let it push.
The show is worse. If you up tonight, we'll get there the right side to booklet.
[inaudible] you can smell the girls hair.
[inaudible].
That's what you shoot a ball. It goes in the hoop. It counts outside.
Monday counts on Saturday counts in India, counts in Africa, counts in America.
That joke killed on Friday night. Both shows Saturday night,
nothing that's comedy.
[Inaudible] I wish he was my mom. Let's go in and drink heavily.
Is it like necessary now? More than ever to have a camera guy doing comedy.
Yeah. Look at this queen over here in the corner. Yeah.
You guys got a black for, I mean, you gotta have your guy.